me again  you know you got to set yourself up for  success all right and link makes that  easier because everything you do on the  computer is synced with your mobile  device and so you can  review your links on your mobile device  you can listen on your mobile device  what you should do you should make sure  that you  create playlists for the lessons that  you're studying so that you can listen  wherever you are  and the playlist also tracks how often  you listen so that this is also  motivating that you know that you've  listened 10 20 times so the same content  still have trouble understanding it but  it's all putting this into your mind  uh there's so many periods of so-called  dead time during the day when you can  listen or review flash cards or even  read your lessons on your mobile device  so take advantage of all the features at  link  and how it works across different  platforms to ensure that you succeed in  your language learning